to
have a good stream happy streaming
all right thanks
uh so hi everyone uh today i'm gonna
talk about
some of the things we've been doing
regarding computer vision
what was that
i think it was from someone else
yeah i think so because i'm
i'm in a quiet environment
i think you can
mute someone if you hear something right
sure can you try to mute me for a second
so because i will be leaving
how to mute
someone in the world yeah in the yeah
yeah over there i guess yeah thank you
okay
so let's continue
so
in this talk i'm gonna tell you a bit
what we've been doing on the vision side
because
most people associate hacking phase with
nlp because it all started with
the burst model
but nowadays uh transformers they seem
to work well on other domains as well
and also i think in 2020 it started with
the vision transformer
which was really
an important paper
from google
so there they showed basically that you
can also apply a bird model
but on computer vision tasks so the only
difference between a bird model
and a vision transformer is basically
how you feed the tokens
how you feed the data to the model
because
of course here we are not working with
text we are working with
pixel values with images so what the
authors did was simply
cut an image into patches and then you
basically see your patches as if they
are tokens
and then you
create an embedding vector for every
single patch so that's like an embedding
vector of 768
numbers in the case of a base sized
vision transformer
and then you feed those together with
position embeddings because say a
attention mechanism inside a transformer
encoder is doesn't know about the
positions
uh so we don't so we need to add those
position embeddings uh to it
so just absolute position embeddings
and then you feed those through a
transformer encoder
and then you get
uh basically state-of-the-art
performance but in the beginning uh it
seemed like resnets were still better
uh than vision transformers
because
people are thinking that it has to do
with like the inductive bias that you
have with convolutional modes that you
don't have
for transformer based models but there
was a recent paper actually from the
same team that made the vision
transformer
where they actually show that you can
get the same performance as a resnet
on imagenet in the same amount of
training time so they just had to fix
some things for example
the original one used the final hidden
state of the cls token for doing the
prediction but it turns out that you can
get better predictions if you do an
average pooling over the final hidden
states of all the patches
and then there are some other techniques
i can link the paper
in the discord if you want
but of course this talk is not just
about the vision transformer it's about
everything that hackingface has done for
the
vision for computer vision as a domain
as a whole
so let's start by installing uh the two
libraries which we're gonna use the
hacking phase transforms library which
is library i'm mostly working on
because i'm part of the open source
theme at hackingphase and the datasets
library and i'm also going to install
the tim library because i'm going to
showcase the dtr model
which is a model that i contributed
last year it's a model for object
detection based on transformers but it
uses a convolutional backbone
for which we will need the tim library
so as you already may know
instantiating a model in hugging phase
transformers happens as follows so
basically you can
define a configuration
which is actually a very simple uh class
it just defines like what is the number
of hidden layers you want in your model
what is the hidden size
uh what is the number of attention heads
and so on so it's basically like
defining all the hyper parameters of the
model architecture and then you can
instantiate a model uh with that
configuration so if we do that like here
this will just instantiate a invasion
transformer a vit model but with
randomly initialized weights we are not
initializing it here with any
pre-trained weights because
we are just initializing it with a
configuration object so you can also
print this configuration if you
want to see what's what's in there
so these are all the hyper parameters
related to the architecture of the model
but of course
what we've seen also with birth is the
power of transfer learning
which means that you start from a
pre-trained checkpoint and then you can
fine-tune simply the hat on top
together with the base model
uh so that's why we do have the from
pre-treatment because this allows you to
basically instantiate the weights of a
pre-trained model from the hugging phase
hub
and so if you go to the hub
you will see that we have dozens of
models
available
so you can just
find one in the search bar
so
the vision transformer was the one that
we started with so let's take for
example this checkpoint
and then you can simply it's already
filled in here you can basically just
call the front pre-trained method on it
it will load
well if the checkpoint on the hip
already has a fine-tuned head then it
will also include that hat
if the checkpoint you're loading from
the hub doesn't include a heads which is
the case for
for example
this one here which is just a
pre-trained one without a fine-tuned
head then it will
do the same thing it will instantiate
the base model but it will not
instantiate the head on well it will
basically randomly initialize the head
on top
so we could use this model here for
fine-tuning on our custom data set
for which i will link some resources
below
and then yeah as you may or not know i
think you already know but every single
model or every single data set or every
single hugging face space is basically a
github repo
so digging facehub is based on get lfs
which is
uh get large file storage because uh
regular git that you have on github only
works for smaller files but of course we
do have these big files here that
contain the weights of the model so they
are
like hundreds of megabytes or gigabytes
large so that's why we're leveraging uh
git lfs for that so basically that is
actually very nice because you have like
a git history uh you can basically have
the same thing you do for code but now
for machine learning models where you
can have you can even add branches
so this is the main branch of the vision
transformer checkpoint
and so the nice thing is also that the
front pre-trained method allows you to
refer back to a specific branch or
specific
commit hash so for example here i just
let me go back to the vision transformer
you can simply go to the files and
versions step then to the git history
and select like one specific commit you
want to refer to and simply provide that
to the from pre-trained methods and it
will instantiate the model at that
particular moment in time so it's yeah
it's basically gets versioning for
machine learning models
um
yeah i'm loading here a vit for image
classification which will actually
instantiate the python implementation
typically in hugging phase the models
are first implemented in pytorch
and the other frameworks
tensorflow and jax flags which we now
also support
are typically implemented thereafter so
if you want to load it in tensorflow
it's as easy as just
adding tf in front
so currently i think
yeah we do have about 20 vision
backbones in the library um just image
classifiers
and the ones that are available in
tensorflow right now are
the following vit then this one which is
based on the vision transformer itself
be it by microsoft
then there's convenience by facebook uh
stream transformer by
microsoft as well and data to vec vision
which is a new one a multi-modal model
all right
but then i also want to showcase that
you can basically
if you have loaded a model
like here let's say we want to load or
instantiate this model uh this this is a
vision transformer just with two hidden
layers
then you can simply call dot push to
help
uh on the model and it will then
uh push it to the hip
so
that's super easy because super nice
because then you can reload it back
again using the front pre-trained
methods and you can also specify if you
want to push it to a private trip on the
hub or a public repo because
it may be that you and your colleagues
for example you want to leverage the
private hugging face up which is
basically the same thing as the public
hub
but in that case yeah the models are
hidden only for you and your colleagues
assuming you have an organization for
example on the hub
then it could be very nice for like
collaborating with other people but
let's say we just
want to push it here to a um so yeah
first it's gonna say that that i have to
authenticate with the hub
so that's why you can use this comment
here hanging face cli login
there's another comment as well for if
you want to work in a notebook but
this
works fine so you can just provide your
authentication token and then you can
call
push to help on your model and then you
can reload it back again as seen here
which is very cool
so it will automatically create a repo
on the hub so you can add a model card
with a read well that's basically a
readme so you can say like vision
transformer
well let's see it's already pushed so
let's add here for example
some text and then it will appear in
your model card and the python model.bin
file has been out uploaded so as it was
a vision transformer just with two
hidden layers
the file is also very very small
all right um
and then what we also have um you need a
thing right to prepare the data for your
model so for
text-based transformation models like
birth roberta gpt2 and so on we have a
tokenizer because you need to tokenize
your text in order to prepare them for
the model
for for vision models as well as speech
models we do provide what is called a
feature extractor so a feature extractor
is like a minimal object that you can
use to prepare images for a model
so it's
uh
you can instantiate it as follows
so basically the two things here they
will instantiate the same thing the only
difference if you call from pre-trained
on a feature extractor is that it will
then first
look for so let's go to this repo again
then it will look for the preprocessor
json file so basically then it will make
sure that your feature extractor is
associated with the following uh
attribute values
uh you can of course just instantiate a
default one
um and so as you can see it will just
perform some very simple image
transformations namely it will
resize your images to a fixed size
for example the vision transformer
expects images to be two to four by two
to four
and then it will normalize the channels
using this mean and standard deviation
and so yeah i'll show in a bit how you
can then uh prepare an image for the
model using the feature extractor and
then do a four pass
what i also wanted to talk about is the
auto api or the o2 classes so basically
here we associated a vit feature
extractor and we instantiated a vit for
image classification
but actually we do provide this handy
api called auto
feature extractor and auto model for
image classification for instance
and you just need to provide a
checkpoint from the hub like
microsoft's resnet50
and then it will instantiate the
appropriate class for you so in this
case um based on the checkpoint on the
up it knows that it needs to load a
resonance for image classification if i
would have provided here a swing
transformer it would automatically load
a swin
for image classification so yeah that's
the auto classes so you can find the
you can find this also in the
documentation and so we do provide them
for a lot of
a lot of tasks like sequence
classification question answering image
classification object detection
and so on and it's actually also a nice
way to see
which models are currently supported for
one particular task so if you
for example want to know which models
are currently supported for image
classification you can see a nice
overview here
so as you can see currently we do
provide
quite a few
models so okay let's do a forward pass
with a model so
i'm typically working with the cat's
image from the cocoa data set because
it's very handy as it allows me to
quickly verify four passes with moles um
so the first thing we'll do is we
prepare it for the model using our
feature extractor
so the api is entirely the same as the
tokenizers so you need to provide this
argument here that you want to have by
torch sensors returned
so here we do we don't have input ids to
feed to our model here we have pixel
values and they have a shape of batch
size so here we only have a single image
a number of channels height width then
you can do a four pass so
i think i loaded here the resonantly
lost so
it will do a four-part on the resonant
model
and then you can do an arcmax operation
on the logits which come out of the
model to get like the highest score in
this case it's
the class with index 282 but of course
we would like to know the
the actual class name so for that you
can leverage the id to label mapping of
the model's configuration so in this
case it has predicted the egyptian
cat from the
imagenet dataset because this particular
resnet model was fine-tuned on or
pre-trained on imagenet 1k
then the next thing i would like to talk
about is a pipeline api um so basically
here we we had to do the data
preparation ourselves so we had to
use the feature extractor to prepare it
for the model and then do four pass then
do an arcmax operation then
convert it using id to label the
pipelines in higginface
they basically are
very handy things for quickly doing
inference with models so they do all the
complexity for you
they absorbed it away for you so we do
have them for several tasks including
image classification
image segmentation object detection and
so on with more and more of these
pipelines coming
and so
you can just load a pipeline like so
um so here it will default to the vision
transformer because we are not feeling
any or providing any model and then you
can simply provide either a pillow image
as we can do here or a
url to a particular image and as you can
see it returns the top five predicted
classes which is very nice it does
everything for us
and so you can also easily load
a model from the app like here i'm
loading a
swing transformer from the app
so let's go back to the
hub so here for example the spin
transformer
which is a more more powerful vision
transformer basically
there was a talk about it not so long
ago
um let's see what the swim transformer
predicts on this particular image
so yeah typically these models always
predict
either egyptian cat or tabby cat
on our image as you can see it's the
case here
and you can also load like if you want
to load your own feature extractor
animal that's also possible so here i'm
loading a convex model
which is also one of these latest models
from facebook and as you can see here it
predicts uh tabby cats
so that's for the image classification
pipeline but as i said there are other
tasks as well so
one model that i actually two models
that i worked on one is the dtr model
from facebook
so they basically showed that a
transformer encoder decoder
could be trained like fully end to end
for object
detection and this is actually
much much simpler than the
existing things that they that there are
like mask rcnn and foster rcnn which
have about the same performance but they
are very very complex
so here they just use a convolutional
backbone they feed that to a transformer
encoder decoder and outcome the
bounding boxes together with the classes
and so and so i decided to also
contribute this one
to do the hacking face library and so we
also built this nice inference widgets
for it so this is actually using the
pipeline
so you can also upload your own
image and it will automatically do the
inference for you and it's very
interactive so that's pretty nice
uh so you can load the object detection
pipeline as follows
it will instantiate to the
facebook dtr model with the resnet 50
backbone
because this is like the default
checkpoint that facebook provided
and then
if you call it on your image it will
return a list
of dictionaries where each dictionary
contains a particular bounding box
particular label
and a confidence score so here it has
detected for example two remotes a couch
and two cats so we can also visualize
this
as follows
so this is what comes out um and so yeah
currently we do provide two objects uh
detection
models in the library which has uh dtr
the other one is uh yolos
which is a model that basically shows
that a
that's a single transformer encoder
uh so basically it shows that you don't
really need the convolutional backbone
and the transformer encoder decoder like
a single transformer
encoder will will work just as well for
object detection
and you can just add the heads on top
so this model is trained using the same
loss as dtr
so yeah that's for object detection but
of course there are more
there will be more object detection
models uh coming in in the new future
then we also have image segmentation
which is a task of labeling every pixel
of an image
with a certain class so if you don't
provide any model
it will
default to the d terminal which was also
shown to
be able to do
panoptix segmentation so we also provide
this info and this interactive widget
for it
so yeah
in this case yeah panoptex segmentation
is actually a bit more complex than just
semantic segmentation so
in semantic segmentation the goal is to
label every single pixel of an image and
then you have instant segmentation where
you also want to define the
identify the
instances like the objects or persons
individual persons in an image
but object segmentation is then like the
combination of both instant segmentation
and semantic segmentation so it will
basically
predict two labels or two classes for
every pixel in an image
um yeah the visualization if i wanted to
visualize this it's pretty
like quite a lot of code so i refer to
my notebook
which i made in my transformers
tutorials repo so here you can see how
they extend
the dtr model for doing panoptix
segmentation and then yeah
i show how you can do
these nice visualizations for panoptix
segmentation with the
dtr model
um and then we also provide
so this was panoplex segmentation but
i've also worked on sagformer which is a
purely semantic segmentation model so
that one
is also available there's a notebook
available in my transformers tutorial
repo for that so let's say you have this
image and you want to label every single
pixel with a certain class
you can use segformer for that so the
api is in exactly the same you use your
feature extractor to prepare
the image for the model uh which returns
the pixel values and then you do four
paths to get your logits out and
for visualization in the case of
semantic segmentation uh
we use the so-called color palette to
basically turn every
class into like a color basically
and this is what comes out
and this is the ground truth
and yeah another one that we now has is
mask former
which was contributed by francesco it's
basically uh
it uses swim transformer as a backbone
combined with a
pixel decoder as well as a transformer
decoder the model is quite complex
and it can do both semantic as well as
panoptex segmentation so notebooks for
that are also available
um in my transformers tutorials repo but
you can always go to the
documentation so if you search for mask
former here you find the api reference
for it
okay and then yeah we also have some
other models as well now we don't have
pipelines for them yet nor do we have
inference widgets but these will come in
the near future for sure so one of them
is called dpt or dense prediction
transformer so this one can do
depth estimation but it can also do
semantic segmentation but here i'm
loading the dpt for depth estimation
model
and was trained on i think 1.4 million
images so basically you can use it for
zero shots
depth estimation
i'm not sure why it's taking
a bit long but yeah here is the result
on our cat's image
so
uh we do have another one uh glpn
but this one was
this one is actually currently state of
the art on papers with codes
at least the one that is open source
and
this one
they do provide we do provide two
checkpoints one is fine tuned on the nyu
data set the other one is finding on the
kitty dataset boats
both are important benchmarks for doing
monocular depth estimation and it's
actually based on sac former this one
so again you can just find it in the
documentation
of failing phase as well as tutorials
you can find them in the transformers
tutorials
repo and github
and another one i did
is the perceiver
perceiver is actually a multi-modal
model and i'm not going to do a
four-pass here because it takes like
80 seconds or something on a cpu so this
is the result it can do optical flow
which is another
important task in computer vision
where basically the task is to
predict the 2d displacements for every
pixel in the first image relative to the
second image
and apparently the perceiver is also
state-of-the-art on that so we do
provide that model as well and you can
always check the code for inference in
the gradio demo that i made for it
um so
yeah for an overview of like the tasks
that are really
standardized right now i refer to the
hugging face task so for now
we do have image classification image
segmentation and object detection but
more tasks like depth estimation and
optical flow
will follow in the future
then
so i talked a lot about now the hugging
face transformers library uh to
basically have all of these uh nice
models like the vision transformer
convenex um swim transformer and so on
and of course we do have other uh
libraries as well
which
uh
like the data sets library is the one i
want to talk about now
so the data sets library is also
very very nicely integrated with the hub
so you can basically
load any
data set from the hub so let's say you
want to load cfar
100 data set
we also do have this nice data set
viewer which allows you to directly view
all the images directly in your browser
which is very nice
and that's based on a new feature called
the image feature which is basically
based on on pillow and it actually
allows you to directly
view the images in a notebook so i'm
going to illustrate this
so yeah we do provide
most of these famous image data sets
already
on the hub like imnist fashion immunists
and there are more and more of them
coming like
one of them that we recently added
is imagenet 1k uh so yeah we do have
gated access for it so
the original authors of imagenet wanted
to have this to make sure that anyone
that uses this dataset also shares his
contact information
but once you click on it you can
basically directly
load the imagenet 1k dataset
in a notebook
so
yeah let's show what the image feature
is about so in this case for example it
will load a data set dictionary
so yeah that's just a standard
python dictionary so you can then load
for example the train split
as follows and as you can see
it
includes three features an image a file
label and a course label
and so as you can see you can directly
view an image in your notebook so yeah
the cfr 100 data set has pretty low
resolution
images i think if you check the size
it's only 32 by 32
pixels
and you can check the the label as well
so in this case yeah the fine label is
19 of course we want to know what is the
actual class name
you can actually do that if you check
the
features of the data set as follows you
can see for example that the find label
is of type class label with 100 possible
classes so you can also create an id to
label mapping for it and then you can
see for example that 19
is uh cattle
for instance
um
all right but that's for data sets from
the hub so you can
actually i think i also do have a
section on that uh yeah
i'm going to illustrate it here
so you can also
use the image folder
builder which is actually very nice
because this allows you to
load any custom data sets
like you may have a local folder with
your images
for example here you have folder with
docs and cats images or you have like a
zip file or a
yeah another format i think we do
provide we do support 19 formats in
total uh
then you can simply
do load data sets provide image folder
with your data files and it will load it
as a hurricane phase data set object
directly from a repo
from a remote url for example or a local
folder with your images
so that's very handy because then for
example here i'm loading the
flowers data set
from
i think it's from oxford
and then you can also directly view the
images
in the browser which is very nice
and so similar to models you can also
call push to hub
on data sets and then you can reload
them back again using loads
data sets you can just
reload them back again so here for
example if i want to push this data set
to the app i simply call push to app on
the data set and give it the particular
name so here i want to like you could
again you can add here private equals
true if you want to
make your data set private or only share
it with
the organization you're part of for
example but here for example
i'm
yeah just pushing it
to a public
so as you can see it directly pops up in
my
activity and
you'll need to wait a bit because this
is using some caching mechanism behind
the scenes but
after a while you will also be able to
directly view the images here in your
browser
um
yeah and so i'm using actually the
hacking phase data sets i'm actually
having too much tabs open let's close
some of them
um
so i'm actually using the hacking phase
data sets library and all the example
scripts we provide so in the hacking
phase transformers library
we do provide
an examples folder so if you just check
the
github repo you can go to the examples
folder then select the framework you
like
and then we do provide example scripts
for image classification for image
pre-training as well as semantic
segmentation so let's go here to image
classification
and then you can basically provide a
data set from the hub
to the script and then it will process
it so you can actually view the details
uh here i'm using
torch vision to basically prepare the
images
for the model
but i'm not going to go into detail
but
the hacking phase data sets library you
can easily use it with any data
augmentation library
for example torch vision
but argumentations is another one
for instance
i'll show another notebook on that later
on
so that's for vision only models we also
are now working more and more on
multi-modal models so these are models
that are not only taking
a single modality as inputs like text or
language sorry text or vision
but
yeah we now have models that for example
take both
images and text as inputs and an example
of that
is the build model and let's go to the
documentation of it so the build model
stands for vision and language
transformer
and it's a multi-modal
transformer encoder basically so you
simply provide your text together with
the patches
so similar to the vit and then you can
use the model for doing things like
visual question answering
so for multi-modal models like vilt we
created what is called a processor so a
processor basically is useful for
multi-modal models
like fields
and they internally combine a tokenizer
for the text modality and a feature
extracted for the other modalities which
in this case is
vision
so
it will basically use the tokenizer to
tokenize the text and it will use the
featurex factor behind the scenes to
resize and normalize
the image for the model and then it will
do it will basically combine them
so for example here let's say we have
our cat's image and we want to ask a
question like how many cats are there
in the image
you simply can call your
your processor on this image and the
text
and it will as you can see create the
input ids the token type ids attention
mask for the
text modality as well as the pixel
values and a pixel mask for
the
for the vision modality for the image
and then you can do a four pass as
always
the api is similar so you just get your
logits out
and in this case the
build model is actually not a generative
model it's just in
a classifier basically it's a
multi-label classifier because it
treats the vq
a data set as a multi-label
classification problem so it can just
select
classes out of i think 1300 possible
answers so in this case it has predicted
the answer to which is correct
um so that's for visual question
answering so i
assume that in the future we'll also
have a visual question answering
pipeline as well as an inference widget
for it
another
domain that is
quite popular for transformers is
document ai so
there are a few models in the hacking
phase transformers library that you can
use for processing
documents like pdfs for example so
there's the
layout lm family so the you have layout
lm layout lmv2 and now there's liabilm
v3 there's also a multilingual variant
called layout exilim
and this model is basically very useful
if you want to do
things like form understanding or
receipts understanding or classifying
scanned documents for example or doing
question answering on documents for
example
the layout the lmv3 model is currently
state of the art on that and it's
actually based also on the
on the vision transformer so again we do
provide text together with our image
patches
we feed that to our multi-modal
transformer and then we can find units
on
yeah task of interest
so i do have for example this hugging
face space that shows what you can do
with
layout lmv2 so this one for example
let's say you have an invoice
and you want to detect for example here
what are the questions
uh what are the corresponding answers um
let's open it in a new tab for some
better visual visibility
so here you can see for example it has
labeled every question as blue with the
corresponding bounding box and then the
answer as green
or for example this has been labeled as
header and so leo delm
v3 is actually equivalent it's actually
more efficient than the old mv2 but i
didn't create a new space for it because
it would
uh look the same
um
so yeah i also do provide uh
like for i think almost any model i've
described until now i do have
notebooks on that in my transformers
tutorials
repo so for example if you want to learn
more about layout lm
layout and mv3 for example i do provide
notebooks on them
then there is also the document image
transformer
again this is a model very useful for
processing scan documents
so i also created a space for it
this one can do
among other tasks
other tasks it can do document layout
analysis
so let's say you have this
pdf and you want a model to detect where
the text or the tables appear in a in a
document
you can use the document image
transformer for that
uh so you can see that this comes out
which is very nice
so this model is also available
in the gaming phase transformers
another model i did was tier ocr
so tr ocr can be used
um for doing optical character
recognition with transformers
so the way this model works is it's
actually a
vision encoder decoder model so what it
allows you to do is basically a vision
transformers encoder and a language
model
as a decoder and then you feed in
image as a sequence of patches to the
vision transformer encoder
and then the language decoder will
based on the encoded hidden
representation of the encoder will auto
regressively generate the corresponding
text so in this case and generates the
corresponding text appearing in the
image
so again i do provide
custom notebooks like notebooks for
custom training
in my transform tutorials repo and i
also created a
hacking face space for it
so for example if you have some hand
written text
you can
see that it has correctly predicted the
text
um another model that is very popular
right now on the hub is clip
i think all of you know clip clip is
a model that was trained on 400 million
uh image taxpayers by open ai
the model is actually fairly simple it
just consists of two
transformer encoders one is the vision
transformer one is birds
and you can use it actually to match
image images with texts so you can use
it to basically determine how well a
particular image corresponds to a
particular text because it was trained
in a contrastive way on 400 million
image text pairs
and again we create a processor for this
model so as it's a multi-modal model we
need both a tokenizer for the text
modality we need a feature extractor for
the vision modality so
that's why we do have a clip processor
and then you can for example let's say
you have your cat's image
and you want to
know which of these two texts go
best with this image
then you can feed them to
clip model to the clip model and see for
example that in this case
two cats sitting on the couch
goes much more
with the image than one cat sitting on
the couch for example and we also
actually abstract this away in a
pipeline so if you want to just use it
for inference you can instantiate the
zero shot image classification pipeline
which will default to
the clip model on the hip
as you can see it has a huge number of
downloads currently
um
and so
yeah then you can simply call the
pipeline
on the image text pairs
another class we have is the vision
encoder decoder model class
so actually i already told you about the
tier the t air ocr model
so
yeah let's close some tabs
again
so the tier ocr model was actually an
example of a vision encoder decoder
model so
this class allows you to combine any
transformer vision encoder like vit or
the swin transformer or paid for example
with any language decoder like birth or
gpt2
so here is how you can instantiate and
then save as well as load it back again
a vision encoder decode mode where you
instantiate the weights of the encoder
with the vision
transformer and the weights of the
decoder with a
bird base encased checkpoints
and so an example use case of this well
i've already told you about
optical character recognition
another example is image captioning
so
either for example who is also attacking
face has created a very nice
vision encoder decoding model where he
associated the weights of the encoder
with vit
the weights of the decoder with those of
gpt2 and then he train it
on the cocoa dataset for doing image
captioning
and we can actually
show
how it works
so let's instantiate it from the hub
yeah here here there is no processor
because this was actually a
a custom model
so as you can see we need both the
feature extractor to prepare
our cat's image for the model and then
we need a tokenizer at the end to
basically
decode the predicted ids the predicted
input ids by the model back into text
so yeah i've actually already run this
offline and if you do it so you call the
generate method
on the model
it will predict a cat laying on top of a
couch next to another cat so
that's
a fairly accurate description
then we also have other multi-modal
models in the library currently uh so i
told you already about perceiver io
so perceiver io is a very cool model by
deepmind and that's basically
yeah you can use it on
any modality like audio images
video text
again i do provide tutorial notebooks
for them in my transforms tutorial repo
and there is an extensive
blog as well if you want to learn more
about this model
we also have
this model by facebook or
now it's called meta
that basically shows that you can use
the same training
paradigm for both speech vision as well
as
language and it actually gets state of
the art on each of those but this model
is still
treating every modality independently
but there are more and more models
coming out
like the veiled model or layout mp3 that
combines several modalities at the same
time
and there's a new one actually that we
have not uh communicated about but this
one is called flava
it's also a multi-modal model that we
we will create
notebooks for them in the future so as
you can see here more of more and more
of these models
they are trained on more than one
modality
and then yeah once you've trained the
model
uh we also do provide support for onyx
which is a very efficient format for
storing neural networks
this is often used when
companies want to run algorithms in
production
so we already provide support for
supporting several
vision backbones
to the onyx format
like for example here
it's illustrated how you can convert the
bait model
to onyx
to the onyx runtime
we do provide an entire documentation
for that as well it's located in the
export hacking phase transformers models
section
as you can see this is an overview of
all the models we are currently
supporting
and also
what we are also working on is in other
library called hacking phase optimum
which is a library that you can use to
basically further optimize the
performance of uh moles
uh
tailored to specific hardware so we do
provide techniques like quantization uh
pruning and so on for both onyx runtime
as well as intel neural compressor
as well as several accelerators like
graphcore ipu's habana godi processor
and so on
and so you can also use this library for
doing accelerated training so be sure to
check it out we also recently
introduced a brand new documentation for
it
and then
yeah so the hub as i told you already
hub consists not only of models
so you can actually filter models here
for example we do provide
several tags for
computer vision for example
we also do provides
a vision tag so if you click on one
you can click on the vision tag to see
all the vision
models
we provide data sets but we also provide
now um spaces which are very well these
are actually
hosted environments for
gradio or streamlet demos or static
html
javascript space
and so
these allow you to quickly show off a
machine learning model so i've actually
shown already quite a few uh
hugging face spaces today so
um
i'm mostly using radio for that so
grayio
allows you to very quickly uh build and
share
a machine learning uh model
and so
yeah this one for example showcases the
receiver for doing image classification
so typically when i add a new model to
the hacking fiends transformers library
i created gray demo for it in order to
quickly show inference
with it with it and so you can always go
to the files and versions tab
onto the app.pi implementation as you
can see it's not a lot of code
it's very
fairly straightforward so gradual just
requires you to define a function with a
certain inputs and a certain output and
then you need to provide this function
to the
radio.interface
class and then for example here
i want uh pillow images as inputs and i
want
the top five predicted labels as output
and so grio
then turns it into a very
nice looking application
so i can actually also create one in
cool app so you can just install the
gradio library
yeah of course one that is now currently
very popular is the dali mini
uh
space so as you can see it has more than
950 likes
uh delhi mini
is a replication of delhi one
yeah in a slightly smaller format so
let's say you want to see a christmas
man
playing football
with his friends
then you can simply
oh there's currently too much traffic
well currently uh delhi mini is quite
popular on social media there are some
uh
some famous youtubers using this model
right now or
yeah sharing it with their with their
subscribers so uh that's why there is
currently a lot of traffic
but uh be sure to check it out once it
gets quiet again
so yeah here i'm showcasing for example
how you can create a quick gradual demo
for the vision transformer so basically
we also
radio also supports
checkpoints on the up so you can
directly provide a checkpoint from the
hub like the vision transformer
you can provide for example an example
image like our cats
and then you can uh yeah do the same
thing as in hanging face spaces
all right so
yeah i've shown hugging phase
transformers i've shown hugging phase
data sets i've shown huge face spaces
with radio demos
here i list some resource resources
which you maybe you may find helpful so
of course
the main
place of
for information is the
is the documentation of hanging face
transformers
so if you scroll down you will see
all the models that are currently
available
um
we also as i said we do provide not only
example scripts so these example scripts
we do provide them for image
classification
um
i've created two variants well basically
any example script in the
in the library has two variants one that
uses the working phase trainer and one
that doesn't one that leverages hooking
phase accelerate instead so depending on
what you prefer
you can
select one of these
scripts for fine tuning on a custom data
set
we do provide example notebooks so i
created
some example notebooks that basically do
the same thing as the example scripts
but they go over everything step by step
and so in this
notebook i'm using torch vision for
doing the uh
transformations as you can see here uh
so typically during training you use
some
data augmentation like random horizontal
flips or random resize crops
but
i'm making them now for other frameworks
as well so we already have one for
albumentations which is another popular
library for data augmentation
so
yeah it's basically the same thing but
i have replaced torch vision
with the
transformations provided by
auburn tations
and so yeah there are more coming so i'm
going to make them for cornea
as well as image oak which are two other
popular
frameworks for
data augmentation and more
uh there are some blog posts we also
wrote so there is one on how to find
univision transformer for image
classification um there is one
for fine tuning segformer
to fine-tune the sec former model for
doing
image segmentation well semantic
segmentation
um and of course there is this
transformer tutorials repo which
you may find helpful for
all kinds of tutorials of uh
models in the hacking face transformers
library so
yeah every
every now and then now and then i add a
new notebook so
be sure to check that out
and then i also made a video actually on
um like how you can
fine tune the convex model or basically
any other
vision based model
in the hugging phase transformers
library on your custom data sets
where i go over all the steps starting
with loading the data
preparing the data for the model using a
data augmentation library
and then trainable in native pi torch
so yeah then what's also expected yeah
we're gonna basically standardize uh all
our tasks as well so we started with
image classification
um
but we're gonna standardize other tasks
like object detection panoptix
segmentation pose estimation depth
estimation and so on
and there are also lots and lots of new
models
coming so a model that is going to
become available soon is the mobile vit
model which
works well on the
mobile devices
and then there is also the
levitt model which was actually added
not that long ago
it's already available on the main
branch
so this one is actually the
the model that is currently the best in
terms of trade-off between accuracy and
speed
so
yeah be sure to check that out the api
is
um
the same as all the other vision models
um and if you're interested in
contributing which
i find very nice because i like to help
out people with
getting to open source
helping out with issues or adding an
entirely new model so you can check the
new model
tag on
github so for example today there was
some one that opened an issue for adding
the pyramid vision transformer so if
your enter is interested in contributing
i can
always set up a slack channel and then i
can help you add the model to the
library
and that's what we also did for example
for the levitt model
and yeah we do provide some guides on
how to contribute to transformers so um
yeah for me actually my very first
contribution to hugging face
uh was a tapas model
and
i learned a huge amount of things thanks
to this contribution because yeah i got
to learn how git works how pythorgs work
how tensorflow works because i had to
port this model from tensorflow to
pythorg
um how hugging phase transformers works
so it's basically a huge uh learning
opportunity if you want to get familiar
with how transformers work
how pythagorean works how good works and
how you can
write a high quality code and so on so
yeah i think i've uh
i've been over all of these points so
i'm gonna
upload this notebook as well
to my transformers tutorials repo
because i think it
could be a nice overview of the
vision ecosystem that we have right now
and let's see where we are uh a year
from now
so
thanks a lot for uh
for listening and watching
and
if you have any questions i can answer
them on this card i guess